here are two of the brightest young
stars in the business she's the evenings
second presenter named Shawn the one
won't be replaced by Roger Moore he's of
no particular interest unless you like
energetic talented performers or you're
one of several billion females on the
planet ladies and gentlemen Shawn young
and Rob Lowe
best the award here editing present for
we're - I'm just talking out of sequence
like it we shoot a movie I see you just
showing everyone how important the
editor is to remove it exactly these
very creative people sit hour after hour
cutting together bits and pieces of film
that eventually will tell the finished
story that we will all see up on screen
very few people realize just how
dependent we actors and actresses are on
their talent well we can show them why
don't you give them the edited version
of your opening line we're here to
present the award for best editing the
nominees are
Gabriela Christiani for The Last Emperor
Michael Khan and Peter E burger for
fatal attraction
Frank J Yuri asking for Robocop
Michael Khan for Empire of the Sun
Richard Marx for broadcast news
and the winner is and the winner is
Gabriella Christianity for the Last
Emperor
I have to be short I'm an editor to be
short it's already four five seconds and
to thank all of you at the academy and
Bernardo Bertolucci to be a great
director Jeremy Thomas to find money and
as good ad says and now I'm going home
to cry thank you